[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] em
well happy tuesday
the taco tuesday
will be tonight
good afternoon good morning to all of
you out there
a lot of oscar news going on a lot of
oscar talk going on on the tweety tweets
in the trendy trends today
there's still some politics and some
news you know we heard about the the
former guy you know he stole uh 15 boxes
worth of [ __ ] i guess stole some
furniture i don't know i i think i think
he stole all this [ __ ] because he's
trying to sell it
he's [ __ ] broke
i mean you know the letters with kim
jong-un
the uh you know that the [ __ ] map
where he put the sharpie this is all
gonna be you know and they're just gonna
try to auction this [ __ ] off right
and that's what they're gonna try to do
patty says hi tony hi all
uh caitlyn says she's checking in early
for once
yoda says good morning y'all what the
[ __ ] is going on around here it's crazy
out there
thanks for joining us here on the tony
michaels podcast every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central
two hours every single day
every single day
yesterday we had rachel bitkoffer on did
you guys catch that yesterday morning um
that might be a monday morning thing i
don't know it's been the last several
mondays we had rachel on
yesterday we talked about legitimate
political discourse
and how
actually them doing what they did over
the weekend with the the oh and number
one uh
railing on mike pence nikki haley we're
probably gonna get into that today
nikki haley railing on mike pence for
telling the truth
you're attacking republicans by telling
the truth what does that tell you nikki
you dumb [ __ ]
so we have that going on and then we had
the political legit a legitimate
political discourse
where they censured
liz cheney and adam kinzing are the only
two republicans that are willing to
speak at all truth to power at all even
just a little bit i mean just a [ __ ]
little bit like they're like you know
that whole voting rights thing yeah we
don't want to do that but we're not with
the coup thing
right like liz cheney and adam
kinzinger's stance on democracy is
flimsy at best
they won't even vote for voting rights
like at all not even close
but i mean they're like yeah the whole
dictator coup thing and it's just a you
know
that's just a fascist step too far right
they like their their light they like
their fascism thin veiled you know
deficits debts
you know birth certificates that type of
[ __ ]
that type of [ __ ] you know not like
full-on coup fascism you know where
you're [ __ ] shredding documents of
evidence
when you try to attempt a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
where the national archives has to run
on down to mar-a-lago getting a dusty
ass attic of that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
golf club
that [ __ ] run down piece of [ __ ]
hotel that he's got down there
can you imagine being a member of that
[ __ ] jesus christ i would you
[ __ ] pay that much money
to be in one of his [ __ ] buildings
god damn you'd have to pay me [ __ ]
money to go in that [ __ ] and i
guess he's djing down there now what is
this [ __ ] he's djing i mean this
[ __ ] is absolutely [ __ ] broke
mj says hey hey [ __ ] i'm army
good morning robin good morning
everybody's here this morning i'm glad
to see you guys this week
it's going to be it's going to be a
fantastic week i have a feeling there's
going to be a lot of news this week
i think there's going to be today it's a
lot of the oscars stuff right that's
trending but i'm sure that we'll get
past some of the oscar trending stuff
here
and we'll get to some get to some you
know juicy stuff about these these 15
boxes worth of [ __ ] that this
[ __ ] stole from the white house
he stole the map with the sharpie thing
on it why the [ __ ] would he want that
other than to sell it
you know he's gonna try to see you know
he was gonna try to sell that
[ __ ] come on
no [ __ ] way was he not gonna try to
sell that [ __ ]
100 percent toe
he was gonna try to sell the [ __ ] that
he stole from the white house and you
know
the other thing too is he probably can't
afford to buy furniture
so he had to steal furniture you know
take the mar-a-lago with him you know
spruce it up a bit down there
[ __ ]
trash heap
like i said who in the [ __ ] would go
there and pay money to go there
now [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] we
gonna go down there and eat the
cheeseburger on the mcdonald's
cheeseburger buffet or some [ __ ]
these [ __ ] people
these [ __ ] people guess what today we
have gabe sanchez coming on he's gonna
he's gonna surf the trendy trends and
the tweety tweets with us uh gabe will
be here in just a bit um we're gonna
surf the trendy trends in the tweety
tweets here and just here in just a
minute
um we we have a great interview coming
up this week i hope we can play it
tomorrow or
or thursday
um you guys know jojo from jurors
from the from the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends she joined us to record an
interview and talked about twitter and
the the evolution of her twitter account
and what that twitter account she think
means to her and means to democracy
which i think all your twitter accounts
out there are you pro-democracy tweeters
out there whether you have
200 followers or 200 000 followers i
think you're important
it's very very very important to spread
the message the pro-democracy message
everyone thinks oh well twitter is not
real life
yes but it gets the conversation going
it gets the messaging going
like that's how we do it like how do you
think russia infiltrated our country
through facebook and the [ __ ]
propaganda that they spread around
social media in 2016.
i mean jesus christ they thought that
two [ __ ] emails that someone deleted
where she said oh i'm having a great day
they thought that that was some evil
[ __ ] cabal in a in a basement of a
pizza place think about it
now i'm not saying we should spread lies
but what i am saying is that we can use
what tools we have in front of us to
spread the message
and to make sure that message is on
point
because they're knocking at the door
these fascists
they're knocking at the door we have
paul gozar this morning tweeting
more [ __ ] election misinformation
that [ __ ]
lying to the american public
and he's using the tool that we have to
use
to spread the message to win in 2022.
now we have a lot of good things
happening for 2022 but we can't lose
sight of how [ __ ] dire this situation
is
i mean there's positives here
the election map is not turning out the
way that they want it of course they
they
overindulged in this gerrymandering [ __ ]
in some of these states
way overindulged not the fascist the
fascist overindulged oh man tell me no
come on
[ __ ] drunk on power they are
intoxicated
on the cou
attempt to take the house because that's
their plan votes
their plan is not to have another
violent insurrection
it's not their plan i mean that's that's
that's trump's plan he's all but
announced it a couple weeks ago when he
said i'll pardon you
all the crimes that you commit in my
name i'll pardon you of course he had
the chance to do that with these january
sixers like stuart rhodes the [ __ ]
founder of the oath keepers
speaking of that we did an interview
last week you guys got to go watch this
thing
if you did not watch
tasha adams the estranged ex-wife of
stuart rhodes and his son his estranged
son dakota adams on that interview you
have to go watch it
you have to i mean the part about the
eye patch and how he lost his eye that's
[ __ ] fantastic
it's fantastic piece of material
everyone wants to hear that kind of
stuff but
the things that got me the most is is
some of the story about the oath keeper
and how the oath keeper started and how
it got to be part of this seditious
conspiracy
and more importantly who stuart rhodes
is like what the mindset is
and how that worked into manga and
trumpism and letting
this [ __ ] buffoon try to become
dictator of the united states
just [ __ ] all over the constitution and
rip it up
it's a fantastic interview and i hope we
have dakota on in the next few weeks um
i know there'll probably be more stewart
news um which dakota can come and break
down but i'd really like to hear his
take on more in detail about bundy ranch
and
some of the other details about some of
the other events that the oath keepers
were involved in
now where they were running security or
whatever the [ __ ] they were thinking
they were doing
and then some of the missions of the the
oath keepers and how it changed with
trump so i want to go in more in depth
with the code on that so i hope i hope
he can join us in the next few weeks so
be looking for that
so go watch that interview
um with tasha adams and dakota adams the
estranged family
of stuart rhodes
it's a great interview you can go watch
it alone it's oh i posted it all by
itself
or you can um you can go watch it on the
on the episode it's episode number 69
on youtube so subscribe to the youtube
channel don't forget to do that while
you're here
do not forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel that is super important
you will miss everything
because we are here every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central where we we we
surf the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends
but tomorrow or thursday
tomorrow or thursday we will air the uh
the interview with jojo from jurors so
go give jojo a shout out um i'm hoping
i'm hoping that
we'll have it done and ready to
to release
um
uh the thursday or wednesday or thursday
this week we'll we'll play it you guys
remember her character becky sue we did
a um we did an rnn sketch the really
news now with uh
carl tuckerson from white privilege
tonight
that video is also on youtube um go go
watch that um the the
the carl tuckerson
uh white privilege tonight with becky
sue uh which is one of jojo's characters
which is [ __ ] phenomenal and
hilarious
uh becky sue is just
um a maga sheep and it's hilarious
it's hilarious you gotta go watch it and
she explains what woke's giving is
uh we did it right around thanksgiving
so
we're hoping we can
we we have jojo on for this interview
but we're hoping we can bring becky sue
back on the shows at some point maybe in
a sketch um but uh go go
pay attention this week and set your
reminders for when jojo is on and you
got to watch the interview we love jojo
here at the show
and i love becky sue we love her tweets
um so so make sure to pay attention to
that interview this week
all right i think we i think we we've
said enough announcements maybe we
should get to the
trendy trends and the tweety tweets
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trinity trends
of the day
all the tweety tweets to the trainers
course there's a lot of uh stuff from
the oscars trending today because then i
think this is being announced um have
you guys seen the movie don't look up
i've watched it like
i don't know i've watched i've watched
it at least a dozen [ __ ] times
great [ __ ] movie fantastic [ __ ]
movie
and if someone doesn't win some kind of
award for that [ __ ] well [ __ ] them
it just it's ridiculous but they have to
win something for that movie somewhere
someone has to win money uh one one of
my one of my favorite
characters in the movie is the uh
almost like the don jr spoof that jonah
hill does
he's
[ __ ] with his nose [ __ ] cokehead
now it's fantastic movies fantastic
movies so it's trending today a lot a
lot of that stuff's trending and so
maybe maybe when gabe comes on we'll get
his his opinion too
of uh of who who should win an oscar who
should win an oscar mj says becky sue is
my fave yes becky sue's fantastic
becky sue is fantastic don't forget that
interview this week okay let's get to
the tweet sweets and trend trends let's
make this bigger so you guys can see
okay uh
let's go down the timeline here just a
bit
um
i i tweeted this i think this is true i
said it earlier
uh he stole that [ __ ] to sell it he's
[ __ ] broke
i think that's the case like i don't
think he you know i mean yeah is it
criminal probably maybe you know i don't
know i don't think this is the worst
crime this guy's ever [ __ ]
the worst crime that this guy's ever
committed right
like
this is not the worst crime he stole
[ __ ] and we shouldn't be surprised that
he's stealing [ __ ] he stole [ __ ] his
whole [ __ ] life he stole [ __ ]
people's money his whole life they'd
work for him and he wouldn't pay him
he's done that kind of [ __ ] his whole
life
so i mean you know this shouldn't be a
surprise that he's stealing furniture
and he's trying to sw
swipe documents
but when when i heard that he took the
kim jong-un love letters right when he
took those i was like wait a second what
do those have to do with anything and
then and then i heard this morning it
was the map where he he drew the dick
sharpie or the sharpie dick or whatever
whatever with the hurricane you remember
the sharpie gate remember when he and he
said no no no it's going to alabama and
he
they had this nice little chart printed
and he took a sharpie and [ __ ] edited
it like no one would [ __ ] notice
like why why did he take that why do you
take that well because he's gonna sell
this [ __ ]
he's gonna sell his these [ __ ] things
because he's [ __ ] broke
what do you think the melania nft thing
is
they're [ __ ] broke they need [ __ ]
money they need cash
they need [ __ ] cash um brett my
zealous uh tweets this earlier the right
wing media acts like minus touch
orchestrated and coordinated hit on joe
rogan because we retweeted a video
question mark they deflect and lie
because they know statements they are
defending are indefensible
we will never back down from holding
truth to power
you you guys know that that the mizellas
brothers kind of got in a tif with
portnoy with barstool sports at [ __ ]
alpha cuck
and they they did kind of a little
not really a debate more of a
conversation about this topic of course
portnoy doesn't know how [ __ ] twitter
works no [ __ ] clue how twitter works
he's [ __ ] bonehead
and hey you know i i i i don't give a
i'd have him on portnoy i'd have him on
we i'd have a conversation with that
[ __ ]
uh
but they had a conversation but i i
think this tweet is important and the
reason why it's important is because
is because
alpha cuts gonna alpha cuck like this is
their their modus operandi their mmo
right we see matt and walsh in the
[ __ ] news today and we're gonna get
to that son of a [ __ ]
real fast quick and in a hurry
that [ __ ] transphobic bigot
[ __ ]
i'm gonna rip him a new [ __ ] today
[ __ ] him
he's scared he's scared that he may find
a woman who used to be a man attractive
he's [ __ ] terrified a little [ __ ]
okay
mayo says karma is coming for donald
trump i i think that's
that's a fair statement
what is what does ty have to say here i
can't wait
i can't wait i look at look at you guys
look at you guys all excited
all excited
well karma's a [ __ ] ain't it i'm not
superstitious but you know karma can be
good okay i i found this look at this
[ __ ]
this is this is what i see
this is what i see when i uh
when i think of donald trump trying to
sell his [ __ ] his his sharpie his his
tornado hurricane sharpie gate thing
like he's got all this like look at this
look back here he's probably got all his
documents that he's going to sell his
kim jong-un love letters uh back here
this is [ __ ] hilarious um who who
would who would
love to see
more than more than the trumps going to
prison for them to be flat [ __ ] broke
and not being able to pretend to be rich
like they do now
not pretending to be rich oh here's the
link here
i'll retweet this this is the link for
the interview that i was talking about
earlier stuart rhodes
ex-wife and son tasha and dakota adams
there's the link
that's at the top of the timeline um
here's the matt walsh thing i said matt
walsh is a creepy weirdo i don't know if
you guys heard but matt walsh has opened
up his own [ __ ] fake ass organization
to try to trick trans people into doing
a documentary a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
so we're gonna go through we're gonna
we're gonna we're definitely gonna go
through that and the reason why is
because matt walsh is obsessed with
other people's genitalia
he's a [ __ ] weirdo and it's [ __ ]
gross what is wrong with these [ __ ]
people
they're absolutely [ __ ] obsessed they
can't help themselves
obsessed with what other people's
genitalia is doing why don't you worry
about your own [ __ ] genitalia there
son you
[ __ ] weirdo jesus christ
now let's see uh we the people says
improperly
you mean he stole other documents not
his
maggie haberman really steps in it here
when she says improperly taking
documents improperly
are you talking about he [ __ ] stole
the [ __ ]
improperly
come on
bernie made off and improperly took
people's [ __ ] retirements get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
come on maggie get it together
get it to [ __ ] gather stole
stole he was stealing
and who he was stealing from was us
that's our [ __ ] that's you that's the we
the people stuff that's the thing that
this [ __ ] doesn't understand and
it's obvious
it's clear that he doesn't understand
this [ __ ] and neither do these [ __ ]
fascists
that that office that he that he
occupied for the four years because
let's face it he didn't do any [ __ ]
work
he [ __ ] he [ __ ] kicked his orange
[ __ ] nasty toenails up on the desk
watched fox news and oan and newsmax the
whole [ __ ] time and tweeted that's
what he did he didn't do anything that
[ __ ] but that's our office
anything that he did that's ours it's
ours it's the american people
not [ __ ] his it ain't his it ain't
bidens it ain't obama's that's what
these [ __ ] don't understand is
that pro-democracy people don't give two
[ __ ] who the president is
they don't they don't give two [ __ ]
what the person is they care about what
they're doing in the office
right
are you working for us the people are
you not
you [ __ ]
okay um so here is uh me me no likey the
truth nikki haley is on fox news let's
play this uh let's play this clip
let's drag on her for just just a just a
bit
let's do it uh she's on bret bear i
didn't know he was still on fox news
like this guy this guy's you know
he's not he's not a he doesn't bow down
and put his cheeto dust knee pads on
most of the time and sometimes he does
but i didn't know you were still over
there i don't watch fox news i don't
have cable i don't even watch any
[ __ ] news really
that's right tony michaels does not
watch news
i don't have cable if i cut cable off a
long time ago you don't need that [ __ ] i
don't know i i don't need the [ __ ]
the noise with these [ __ ] well let's
listen to nikki haley respond to brad
here
president trump is wrong yes he is i had
no right to overturn no you did not the
presidency belongs to the american
people yep and the american people alone
that's it and frankly there is no idea
more on america yeah than the notion
that any one person could choose the
america exactly
why in the [ __ ] is it that that that
people have to stand in front of a
microphone a former vice president
united states has to stand in front of a
microphone and tell his party
those simple [ __ ] facts
think about that for a second that's
where we're at in this [ __ ] timeline
he has to stand in front of the
federalist society and tell them those
simple [ __ ] facts
listen to it again listen to what he
says listen
president trump is wrong yes fact
i had no right to overturn the election
fact yes you don't you did not and you
didn't have the ability either the
presidency belongs to the american
people and the american people alone
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock
no [ __ ] sherlock we elected these
[ __ ]
rather through the popular vote at
electoral college we elect these
[ __ ] it's ours it's our
government
and frankly there is no idea more on
american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president this
is [ __ ] not rocket science but he has
to stand in front of a microphone and
tell his party this
think about this and they're all like no
you're wrong you're wrong it totally the
office of the president is totally
belongs to donald trump 100 full stop
always has always will we want
authoritarianism
and you're wrong pence you're wrong
you did have the right to overturn one
person one person has the right to
choose who the president is that's how
democracy works
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
under the constitution i had no right to
change the outcome of our election
or the ability
like literally you know this [ __ ] you
know it did some people say oh we were
on the brink which we were we're on the
brink of [ __ ] absolute chaos that's
what they wanted they wanted chaos they
i don't think they were going to get
what they wanted out of pence saying
well i'm not going to have these
electors right
but
it may be
maybe but i don't think i don't think it
was even a possibility
and kamala harris will have no right
to overturn the election when we beat
them in 2024
he's running
that right there
right there
that's his that's his game now i will
have to say because i haven't commented
on this video yet
but i know that this speech was not mike
pence's idea mike pence did this was not
his he's a weak piece of [ __ ] there's no
way that this speech was mike pence's
idea
but who's whoever idea this was
whoever's idea this was is [ __ ]
brilliant
they're probably a fascist but they're
[ __ ] brilliant to come out and give
this speech the way he gave it
because they i i mean they do oh well
he's going to get applause
he's going to get applause here at the
federal society when they did apply
oh man can you imagine getting under the
skin of the cheeto dust mobster you know
really smoking out this fascism now i
don't know if mike pence mike pence can
get the nomination but i do know this in
in white rule america a lot of people
held quote unquote held their nose
then voted for donald trump because they
love this [ __ ] this this [ __ ]
homophobe
they love this [ __ ] homophobe oh they
love him they [ __ ] love mike pence
these [ __ ] evangelical types you know
these [ __ ] the deplorables
as hillary clinton called them now we
know that's the [ __ ] truth they were
like oh you can't calm the [ __ ] that
they're indecent human beings they're
indecent
what are you gonna do
and we can we don't have to tolerate the
intolerant
like mike pence here but they love the
intolerant they love him
because you know he doesn't do the
bombast thing like trump you know and
and you know do all this he's more
evangelically
or whatever i don't know is that a
[ __ ] word
but this [ __ ] this [ __ ] whoever came up
with this speech and had this idea
[ __ ] brilliant
[ __ ] brilliant and this is the
beautiful part about this is this is
driving wedges in between them folks
like this speech right here right here
right here just [ __ ] replay this
[ __ ] over and over and over
again go to your [ __ ] family right
your trump humping [ __ ] family you
know those [ __ ] who voted for
trump twice who told you who told you in
2016. oh yeah trump trump will win but
he'll be impeached and then mike pence
will be our president
and they're still on the trump train
show him this [ __ ]
call him out
call him out what did you know who do
you support you support trump or pence
which is it [ __ ]
this is the perfect wedge to drive in
between them i'm telling you our
messaging should center around mike
pence's words right here
that trump is wrong
he's full of [ __ ] [ __ ] one person
doesn't have the right to to control our
government
which we the people cut it up i don't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] make it something
different you remember back in uh 2012.
remember this when mitt romney is
running and then barack obama was
talking about roads and bridges and he
said if you got a business you didn't
build that he was talking about roads
and bridges right not the business
itself but they cut it up
they cut it up to sound like that [ __ ]
them cut this [ __ ] up cut this [ __ ] up
and let's [ __ ] beat these
[ __ ]
that's what i say
well he said it he said it let's cut it
up
okay let's continue
so your thoughts on that and about the
focus on here we go with [ __ ] here
well you know i think look mike pence is
a good man he's an honest man i think he
did what he thought was right um on that
day but i will always say i just i'm not
a fan of republicans going against
republicans
it's so sad it's so sad when you use
truth and facts
to attack someone give me get the [ __ ]
out of here no one's attacking anyone he
stood on stage and just said facts
that's where they're at even nikki haley
can't even go on fox news and say yeah
you know
he's telling the truth
right nope now you're attacking other
repel oh you're attacking our dictator
you're attacking grandpa poopypants and
he's sensitive
the [ __ ] out of here because the only
ones that win when that happens are the
democrats in the media do you hear what
she's telling you do you hear this let's
back it up
listen to what she says here
she's telling you what they're scared of
right she's saying it out loud on fox
news because she doesn't think we're all
listening she thinks it's just [ __ ]
trump lodi listening right well i mean
she's saying this for one person like
one person alone that's it
just one audience of one [ __ ]
down at mar-a-lago shuffling through his
boxes of love letters from kim jong-un
listen pence is a good man he's an
honest man i think he did what he
thought was right um on that day but i
will always say i just i'm not a fan of
republicans going against republicans
because the only ones that win when that
happens are the democrats in the media
the democrats in the media
notice how they put us with the media
like we like the [ __ ] media or some
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here like we're
fans of the media right now come on we
want the free press we don't want the
[ __ ] [ __ ] press right we want a
free press that's what we want we want
more democracy that's what we want
[ __ ] nikki haley she's telling you
she's telling you what she's scared of
she's telling you she's saying it out
loud let's give credit
if we read it we give credit or if we
watch it we give cred i need to come up
with a phrase like that we watch it
i don't know maybe you can make me know
so so anyone out there who's really good
at cutting up political videos i'm what
i'm saying is don't take this footage
from the federalist society of mike
pence saying this stuff and cut it up
and make it to our advantage i'm saying
don't do that
i would definitely not spread that
around like herpes i would not do it yes
i would [ __ ] them
okay let's set
um oh yeah
here's my tweet about the 15 boxes
who doesn't have 15 goddamn it
there we go zoom feature the zoom
feature just was not not participating
here
my tweet about the 15 boxes of
improperly removed material get the [ __ ]
out of here who doesn't have 15 boxes of
quote unquote improperly removed white
house documents stored in the attic of
their south florida's [ __ ] golf club
come on
get the [ __ ] out of here improperly
removed
maggie you can do better than this you
can do way better than this oh this
one's from mayo it's hilarious
you know that mayo is a fan mail are you
out there this morning uh trump's
america is just fascism with the spray
tan
oh [ __ ]
mayo do not stop do not quit ever please
do not do not stop that um here's a
video of uh from patriot takes a
marjorie taylor green
on the floor of the house
bitching about mask
let's listen
thank you mr speaker i'd like to talk
about how children feel about mask
you see while they're watching
television
seeing super bowl games where adults are
filled
filling stadiums she sounds like out of
breath didn't she like she seems really
[ __ ] winded like a coveted type
winded without mask and enjoying
themselves while they see
concerts happen they see people go to
work they see adults
all right
let's move on here actually you know
what we got we got we got someone coming
in here let's take a break uh right
after these messages we'll be right back
stay with us don't go anywhere
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
as i promised we have someone here with
us
you know him as the executive producer
co-host and guy who can't run his
microphone half the time
he gave sanchez oh he's got his mic on
now he's got his mic i was trying to i
was trying to queue you in like oh you
put turning i mean i could have
yeah yeah yep right i can't i can't yeah
right
how you doing today gabe oh you know
we're just watching uh marjory taylor
green uh yeah you know gas broken
the people of georgia
i guess they're i guess the regeneron
didn't work i don't know maybe the idea
isn't kicking in yeah you know it is
always funny like this is the cure this
is how you cure covid and then they get
cobit you know it's like hey guys maybe
just stick with the vaccine that like
maybe makes this you know the symptoms
much or far less than what they would be
when you're drinking your own piss but
you know whatever yeah you know wait i i
hear there's a new thing
someone said who was it oh yeah it was
it was on the uh interview with joe yeah
yeah she talked about like needles or
something right right and i was like you
know what just drink pine salt call
today well you know yeah yeah the dish
looks like it looks like piss it does it
looks like this that has the word pine
in it it might smell like pine trees
maybe they'll just go with that maybe
they'll just continue that down that
road so have you if you've been looking
at twitter this morning there's a lot of
oscar stuff on there uh yes i did look
at a couple things uh around the oscars
mm-hmm what do you think who's gonna win
this thing you think who's oh boy i
gotta go i gotta look at the full list
again oh yeah i saw kirsten johnson uh
jesse plummons were both nominated right
yeah which is cool because they're
partners
uh and they're both in the same film
together so that's kind of cool
i have not seen uh
their film yet
but right on my list oh okay but what
about don't look up i love that movie i
don't look like yes i watched it
yeah it was nominated for what
screenplay and best picture yeah i think
something like that yeah yeah
it needs to win something that movie
right yeah yeah i mean it's
it's very on the nose for what's going
on you know oh yeah right
did you think did you think that movie
was about
about like what's going on right now
like the coronavirus or do you think it
was more about climate change what do
you think it was really trying to sit in
the signal board or is it just humanity
in general like i mean i would
you could say like the downfall of
humanity for sure but i would say uh
it's definitely climate change
but also
it is about um
just the way that we i think because
you know they filmed it i don't know
when i
forgot when they said it was written but
it was definitely filmed during cobin
and what i can say is like you can take
that same ideology the same mentality
that they have and and apply it to cobit
right like oh well don't report the
numbers
less cases less coveted right like don't
look up you'll never see that right
you can almost apply that a movie to
every single decision that the trump
administration made oh yeah yeah
definitely almost every single one like
even even
sharpie gate has come back now because
he stole the [ __ ] you know the poster
board did you hear this he stole the
poster board like why the [ __ ] did he
steal the post board he's going to sell
it that's what he's trying to do he
wouldn't oh yeah he saw the son of a
[ __ ] there's no way he wasn't going to
try something some person's going to put
they're going to refinance their home to
get the amount of money to buy that
thing on ebay that's what they're going
to do
these people will go broke again and
again and file for bankruptcy and then
again and again just so that they can
have a little taste
of the trumpy right of the cheeto dust
so so do you think do you think he would
copy
the poster board or do you think he
would sell the original like he would
copy it and then sell it as an array of
the copy right right as an original
right right right even though he would
be talking on ebay like yeah this is
totally totally real totally right yeah
he would you know i wouldn't be
surprised if if uh
if he started scanning these things then
trying to sell him his nfts you know
well that's kind of what my my theory
was was because you know melania you
know they she's done the nft they're
just like you know they're trying it out
a bit before they do that right right
they're doing their testing
and that's what the love letters was
about too either that or he's jerking
off to him or something i don't know i'm
working on a video right now is there a
video coming there is a video coming uh
not today but but i think tomorrow yeah
but basically is uh it's just like the
things that the national ar archive like
retrievers found in these texas can you
imagine being that team of people
they're like we need to go where
mar-a-lago we have to go we have to fly
down
and we have to so you had burn bags
okay
did we locate the 15 boxes are we sure
there was only 15 boxes they're like
well as of right now that's what we
think we were missing and you know turns
out there's probably like another 15
somewhere
you know
it's like he was stumbling he was he was
stealing [ __ ] furniture too yeah i
wouldn't be they take that [ __ ] back
with them on the planet okay so i saw
someone post something that said steal
the chairs that was ripped up and taped
together
and what i'm trying to figure out is
where did that come from either somebody
made it or it was something because i
want to know where did p where did you
hear this thing about the uh the
furniture
where did i hear about it yeah yeah
where the [ __ ] do you think i heard i
heard about it on twitter i heard about
it on twitter okay of course and you
know whatever right of course i don't
know if it's real or not
i'm trying to figure out like if it is
real and they went down and got the
boxes did they take the furniture with
them like they're like hey that's a
[ __ ] chair from the white house what
the hell is right like it has the tag on
the property of the white house
furniture
trump yeah all right i'm sure like i'll
get something if you get the thread send
the threat over we'll look at it here
yeah yeah but no no i mean
listen i i
i i think that this guy on his way out
he was like he wasn't like oh i gotta
take this stuff so no one sees it right
right like he's like i want this stuff
because i bet i could sell it for you
know you know his thought like this is
worth a hundred million dollars because
it has my name on it you know like that
kind of right yeah yeah that's why we're
taking these [ __ ] boxes uh i mean the
the thing i do remember is
is remember that photo that got released
where they were like taking the lincoln
bust out of the white house
yeah yeah we're not like they're
carrying it they're carrying all kinds
of [ __ ] out right right so like that's
the only thing i can remember
uh
[Music]
is
is
like a physical object that we saw that
was being taken out because i remember
that part right because that was that
was probably like like the the the most
common
uh picture that was spread around
twitter when that was happening right
right right that that week before the
inauguration yeah yeah that was like the
15th or something like that right and so
yeah i don't know if i can find
something obviously like it's definitely
you know
uh very much on brand for uh
the trumpers you know so it makes sense
why he would steal the furniture they're
over here right they stole the lectern
right yeah yeah they're like yeah here's
the podium gonna take it
uh so yeah you know i'm still working on
some ideas of just outrageous things you
know who knows he was probably you know
i you know he's probably got another
like 10 15 boxes that he that he's got
hidden underneath like the 18th hole at
mar-a-lago golf course you know right
right um
so
i don't know but yes the furniture thing
i can't find like an actual article that
talks about it
but people are saying that he stole
furniture what do you think about maggie
haberman is saying improperly removed
come on
get the [ __ ] out of here
come on no no no
properly no they stole it it took a year
over a year
for them to get that back right or i
guess about a year to get that back
because they said they retrieved it in
the middle of january and it's just
being reported right now so what i want
to know is how can someone like maggie
haverman like really improperly removed
no it wasn't it was stolen with intent
they weren't they weren't like hey
listen we're just gonna like take this
you know for like we're just gonna like
rent it for like a little bit is that
cool is that cool that's not cool uh
don't worry about it so here's the
problem here that i see is that
everyone's like arrest him for the
presidential records act and i'm like oh
my god the problem is is that this is i
i don't even know if it's a crime like
necessarily like kind of like the hatch
act like they don't really you know it's
not like it's illegal but right but it
is a crime right but it's like
you know
it's
obviously uh the crime would be
obstruction if he's actually trying to
hide documents that have something to do
with january 6. like that's the actual
crime right yeah yeah but this this
taking this stuff from the white house
and in particular the records um because
they're ours right and this is why this
is why normally a president has a
presidential library because what
happens is the national archives
places a lot of those records and
documents in their library right like
obama's got a library uh trump will have
a coloring book factory probably so you
know like
that's where all that's where all the
the trump records will live
but i don't know if he gets a library
maybe he thought he wouldn't get one so
that's why he had to take all that he's
like oh maybe i'll open my own library
i'll charge people to get in you know
that's right i don't know i i almost
wonder
for any people who've who have read or
watched the show station eleven it's not
it's on hbo max right now i definitely
recommend it however
there's this one there's this part of
the show where they talk about they made
this uh museum of of civilization right
so they have all these little archives
and trinkets and things right that's and
it's
in the uh in the watchtower at the
airport because it takes place you know
post-apocalypse
and
that's what it's not a it's not a
library i think what trump was doing was
he was building himself a little museum
right for people to like you know walk
between the velvet ropes and check out
the little things he's like here i am
with kim jong-un here's the letter
here's a letter from obama here's the
lincoln bust here's the you know right
here's the chair i used when i was in
wwe like
you know there's all these things that
he just has a it's like the trump uh
archive museum
what's funny about this is is i'm from
missouri and if you live in missouri you
have definitely went to branson missouri
which god help you when you get a
branson missouri have you been to
branson missouri before no i only know
branson because she's out of my league
right don't
don't
don't don't go
to branson missouri but when you go to
branson there's all these you know
uh
music stars these country music stars
right that's what branson it's the
the the entertainment country
entertainment capital or whatever the
hell they want to call it right but in
each one of these theaters right for
these country music artists these cheesy
country music artists most of the time
there's like this cheesy [ __ ]
uh museum where they got like their
outfits on mannequins and they've got
like all the trinkets and stuff and then
you can go buy like you know t-shirts
and head you know you go buy merch
there's like a merch you know gift shop
there right right you so you're saying
like mar-a-lago would have something
like that yeah yeah just like you know
exit through the gift shop like it's
right right you go you go in you pay you
pay you know of course he would charge
probably like a thousand dollars yeah
you know what people would people like
his fans and followers and cult members
would would pay it right you know so
they walk through this muse this this
cheesy ass museum it's probably not very
big like there's not gonna be a lot of
[ __ ] in it right like like maybe maybe
one room full of like these glass like
because you wouldn't want anyone to
touch it you know right yeah yeah and
you walk through and then on the other
side like the gift shop is just like a
whole warehouse just full of just oh
yeah like flag you know cheap ass flags
from trump flags from china like the old
ones too like trump 2016 2020 yeah like
all the ones that are left over he's
trying to sell those [ __ ] in
the gift shop right
yeah
and it's like the costco of gift shops
probably yeah but each one is
is labeled as the original right right
right right it's like everyone's like i
got the original this i got the original
then and it's like you just had a
replica as well right right right right
like you can buy the the letter from kim
jong and the original letter in a stack
of original letters right right right
that was written like in it i don't know
i think i think i think someone out
there who does videos maybe you know i'm
just just floating this out there maybe
it's a good idea all right let's let's
go to the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends here uh so we we watch this
marjorie taylor green video she's
huffing and [ __ ] it sounds like she
might
she might have a virus i don't know i'm
just saying um uh well i mean she is
kind of a virus so well speaking of
speaking of seditionists and traitors
did you see this uh paul gosar
yeah paul gosar and uh
look someone said someone's reading
about it
that's weird sedition as paul goes r
turns off comments on this tweet
promoting election misinformation
guess he doesn't want actual legitimate
political discourse
slam dunk on the phrase there let's go
read this [ __ ] tweet
okay so what is he saying here because i
actually i did i seen the tweet and but
right he's retweeted something here yeah
so he's pushing yeah he's basically
pushing this the misinformation that
there was fraud in the 2020 election
from maricopa county the whole thing
that the [ __ ] cyber ninjas were there
to like figure out turns out they
couldn't find it because it didn't exist
they double counted themselves they
ended up uh giving mine
yeah giving more votes for biden
they paid all this money and spent and
really not just paid for the audit they
spent the arizona's money and maricopa
counties because they destroyed those
machines because they mishandled them
they can't reuse them like it's against
the law they have to they have to
you know they have to get rid of them
and get brand new ones i mean even
watching the footage from when uh the
cyber ninjas were presenting it was like
okay can you show us uh proof that there
was fraud and they're like all right go
so you look over here on this column
here in this column here only and then
realizing that you know they got called
out for the fact that they were double
counting votes for trump so they're like
all these extra votes he won by this
many turns out that they had just done a
2x on that number
well i mean i mean that's how it
find me 11 847 votes underneath the
mattress somewhere please right exactly
that's what that's more of this [ __ ]
yeah if if people haven't figured out
who was trying to steal the election
like and who tries to steal elections
the reason why no republicans voted for
the john lewis voting rights act and the
freedom to vote act the reason why none
of them because they know what would
happen if everyone
everyone has access to a ballot and
everyone actually gave their
i mean their patriotic duty to vote
right
they know what would happen they
wouldn't be in power anywhere exactly so
he's saying here
so is he so is he spreading the the
cyber ninjas 2x misinformation is that
what you're saying
i i don't know if it's specifically that
one i just know it's more misinformation
about how maricopa county was the county
that would have flipped arizona because
there was uh more votes for trump than
there were for biden and obviously like
maricopa county is going to go down as
the
the just like the [ __ ] of the 2020
election because that county has been
dragged through so much stuff in terms
of
oh there was fraud and these people were
working for this group and this you had
these things brought in after at the end
of the night and like all these
different lies that were told and ended
up getting debunked doesn't matter
because like we've talked before it's
you know whoever is first to say that
accusation
or or put that thing online you know
it's the correction that often is
disregarded even though it's it's
debunked right so and i mean i mean
their goal their goal with this this
disinformation
is is to
literally
spread it around as fast as possible so
their little minions and trolls now
um this guy here mark whatever [ __ ] him
finchum i guess is his name
right he looks like he's running for the
secretary of state i'm sure that's not
suspicious at all yeah totally
so let's let's see what um oh he's just
he's just is this guy retweeting an
article of himself here and oh in the
freedom times well god it must be it
must be it must be patriotic and true
yeah um his tweet for the party that
tells everyone else to move on
they sure don't know how to move on
right you know cry more cry more hey
twitter did not ask me if i wanted to
censor myself here they're finally
getting it i don't know
okay um
and paul goes out so he says this is
this is what is crazy about these people
like this guy
does this make any sense 740 000
maricopa 2020 ballots cannot be
authenticated what are you talking about
it's already certified you dumb [ __ ]
yeah lack lack of often authentic
jesus
means exclusion so he's he's saying
because
there's and and this is why they're
pissed off about maricopa county this is
why they're super [ __ ] butthurt about
it because maricopa county was [ __ ]
red like reliably red right this is
where they had tent city tent city at uh
what's his name sheriff joe joe arpaio
oh sheriff joe okay yeah who was later
uh
pardoned right well because he was gonna
see he was gonna be sentenced to federal
prison right and and and and the cheeto
dust mobster had to you know practice a
little bit on the pardon thing
but the margin here is so large that and
that the compelling conclusion this
result cannot be verified
and sir it i already has been what are
you talking about like
do they do they even i mean literally
i i'm not sure if because wendy rogers
is [ __ ]
is his tag on this thing that [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] um carrie lake which is even
worse um and then whoever this guy is
running for state legislator or
something god help us god help arizona
but he must be running for maricopa
county maybe i don't know but anyways
the maricopa county was reliably read
this is what really pisses them off
about it right and that's why they can't
stop [ __ ] focusing on maricopa county
and my hope is is that uh 2022 we get
out and we show them that mark kelly
[ __ ] slam dunks maricopa county turns
that [ __ ] deep blue
those [ __ ] that's what that's that's
what we need to do that's what we need
to show them so this tweet sucks that
tweets oh wait wait wait i can't oh [ __ ]
yeah
i can't tell the the party uh the party
of the first amendment [ __ ] him i'm
telling him i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
telling him one way or the other you
[ __ ] thanks for the tweet no
is that what i did yeah
no now you got to go back
i don't delete tweets either i don't
delete tweets either here we go
this is gonna watch time
he's you know what he's going to do he's
going to screenshot that he's going like
look
look he loves me
he loves me so much and [ __ ]
okay let's see here let's try this again
everyone ready
i hit the wrong button
uh
tell me that's good am i good yeah yeah
okay
great great they didn't censor me either
twitter's getting it twitter's finally
getting it they're like oh the shitless
thing it's not it's not it's not offend
i mean it is offensive but yeah you know
you mean you could report it if you
wanted all right you know um should we
thank this guy for his tweet
oh who's that i don't know this you
already did
no i didn't not for you
i don't think i i you know you tweeted
on it oh you yeah yeah i said i said i
said i said i said what a puss
he is he's a puss he's a [ __ ] paul
gosar is a [ __ ] wimp he is cry more
we lost and we don't want to lose when
you when you have all of your siblings
come out publicly and uh in two
different videos saying that they don't
like you which which is what paul
gosar's uh siblings did then you know
that you're a terrible human right but
who
who in the world likes paul goes-r like
paul goser i mean
nick fuentes yep nick fuentes literally
that's the only guy that likes paw
patrol is nick that [ __ ] racist
white supremacist yeah [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
um outspoken here says paul gosar is
certifiably cuckoo
you get it you get it you get that
you're all cuckoo for cocoa puffs baby
yeah well maybe that's maybe that you
know there was a point when i uh that
happened i was like oh i should make a
thing it says you got cucu for cocoa
puffs and then of course somebody
already said it so i was like well i
can't make it for cocoa puffs i can't
make a meme about it because somebody
already said it ah son of a [ __ ] amy
lynn one of our favorite here paul gozar
is so full of sh
a so full of [ __ ] his family doesn't
even like his ass see that that's what
you were saying right yeah yeah exactly
yeah i mean you know when you're i've
got it yeah i've got a i got a tweet
from a while ago that brings all the
stuff up i have not gone back to go look
at it though i'll be honest with you
there's some of my manga family you know
because some of my family's maga you
know they're making their trumpers they
don't like me so i don't know you know
maybe it could go both ways you know
yeah you know you're saying hey it's
okay who else bring them on the show you
know
so you want to interview you want to
we'll do like a little intervention you
know intervention for who them or me
well
[Music]
[Laughter]
both he says okay so so is it just this
is it just this tweet that he's yeah
it's just
i mean he over like uh you know all over
he's a he's a [ __ ] bag but uh
uh just on that tweet specifically
that's why he's getting called out oh
paul gosar is a [ __ ] bag are you kidding
me crazy
so today's john williams birthday
speaking of um
oscars this guy's like 1 000 of them i
know he's 90 years old that's he just he
like
they're like listen we need a
we need a song for this he goes um okay
how about the whole thing
right and then i'll just i'll just make
the whole movie rocking yeah and then he
like brings out you know as a conductor
he's like tap tap tap tap
and then like this and boom instant hit
you know
well so many movies so many movies from
our childhood were think about it home
alone what would that movie be without
no jurassic park oh what would that be
dude imagine that without that
soundtrack forget about it again forget
about it i mean
really he's like um legendary and
uh
he's probably is he still doing what's
the last movie he did let's go in here
and let's see what's the last movie john
john williams did
happy birthday john williams
like
the okay let's watch let's watch this
video everyone likes john williams come
on we cannot
don't think that any of the scenes that
stephen and i have done in our work
together
uh
were done by having the music first the
bike ride and et is unique in one part
of our experience and say the bike ride
is fantastic the viewers remember it the
the story about about it was that i was
having difficulty putting the music in
the correct sync with the film getting
the lift off right getting the landing
right and so on
and i was conducting the orchestra and
stephen just came out and said well look
why don't you just play the music with
the orchestra the way it feels naturally
musically and i'll re-edit a little bit
here and there to fit
to fit the score
so it's one instance i think that i can
remember where he readjusted his editing
now mine's just slight you know
fractional frames in some cases
microseconds even
but i think the end result gave it a
kind of operatic quality where there's a
wedding
of the forces within the music you know
the kinetics or the dynamics rhythmics
of it
are all intimately wed in a way that
it's hard to do the other way around
brilliant [ __ ] huh
oh my god
like the uh you know of course he's
talking about steven spielberg there i
believe yeah yeah because they're
talking about e.t
right um
which uh again another [ __ ] movie
that you're like what
what would it be without the sound and
you know sometimes people don't notice
the sound of the movie because the sound
fits so well like like you know like
again home alone jurassic park e.t the
sound fits so well with what you're
seeing they really it's almost like you
know you don't even
notice the sound because it fits so well
you know what i mean
i don't know i feel that way he does
yeah he has a
you know
an incredibly innate ability to
to
because like so many soundtracks or like
uh films that we watch as kids where
his music is in there like again i could
not imagine a movie without that they're
so iconic
and like you can you know it's uh what
he also did harry potter right like
right
all of those star wars jaws like in the
background there is like a a a uh a
constant
through line that is john williams right
like i know when you hear it you're like
uh there's like a little hint of this
and a little hint of that like you're
always like oh that's a john williams
score right right uh they're all unique
and different in their own way but in a
basel and like in the base of it there's
like a little thing there's like oh i
can i can hear like when i listen harry
potter i'm like oh i can hear a little
of this so i can hear a little that you
know
so there's pieces where
where they're all like connected in this
john williams universe
and it's again so iconic that i can't
imagine
going back and watching those movies
with someone else trying to now you know
obviously they would be their own kind
of
work of art but there's like a little
thing in my face there sorry uh
but i look at it and i'm like i don't
know
if they would ever be really the same
they're so just powerful and they stand
on their own
so what what is his what is his last
film that he did do you know did you do
you have it there
um
yoda's saying um
is it ep
credit is episode nine what is what is
that oh episode nine that's probably
star wars is what they're referring to
okay so that's his last credit is
episode nine the star wars let's see
which one which one's that called that's
called the the
the last the riser the riser walker yeah
the riser skywalker that's it according
to this that is the
uh
that's the last film according to his
website johnwilliams.org gotcha gotcha
like he worked on the post which is a
movie with um
tom hanks
and
uh
uh
meryl streep
and the last jedi
force awakens book thief lincoln
you know he's he's touched so many films
what's up let's watch him let's watch
him actually conduct here this is
wu-tang uh for kids opposed to this the
ability like just a skill like as a
conduct like you know conductors
obviously is great but him
just crazy like
i you know obviously i don't know the
motions and what they like i feel like
there's all these nuances of like subtle
to heart you know to explain the
direction and obviously everyone knowing
like you're you're
you're a cohesive family a unit
so you all know like what these
these motions are are meaning when you
should come on when you should go off
when you should go high when should go
low when you should go you know whatever
um it's impressive you know and
especially to to to
to just hit it every single time on that
scores right and it's but but the crazy
part about it is the feeling that you
get from his music right like oh yeah
like what you're supposed to feel in the
movie is what his like you can see what
you're supposed to see but the music
john williams makes you feel what you're
seeing right right right it's [ __ ]
incredible because that song there um
you know obviously is is when darth
vader comes in right um it it right it's
that's the the empire song which uh is
the song i i have a vision of when dick
cheney walked onto the floor on j on the
the right commemoration of january 6
where they're yeah commemorating the
loss of life and he walks on the floor
with liz cheney like bum bum you know
that the empire exactly i don't know
just but but just that that that sound
of just oh yeah you're deep evil that
because like john
especially like when i'm picking music
uh for different sketches i'm like oh
you know i'm going to put in some fully
sound here and there put his music in
sometimes people may recognize the song
if i'm using it but it's one of those
things where like if you heard that or
any song that he did on anything you
would be like it would just take you out
and be like boom oh i remember when i
was in the theater and i was nine years
you can see it right you can see exactly
you can see it that's how powerful his
work is that's perfect see we don't just
do politics here god damn it
we need pop culture and and uh john john
williams happy nostalgia happy [ __ ]
birthday john williams gabe i know you
got to run um but but audience
stick around we'll go more to the [ __ ]
list i promise we'll do more politics
right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the drew with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
well people are upset in the comments
[Music]
and i did not know the name of that john
williams song from the star wars movie
yoda
our our local
uh star wars hero here veteran yoda is
very upset at me that i do
well what did you your lack of star wars
knowledge disturbs me
easy there easy there no i love star
wars i [ __ ] love stores they're some
of my favorite movies i'm actually my
believe it or not my
the most favorite movie that i i uh of
the star wars series of all the
collection that they have
is uh
is the rogue one i [ __ ] love that
movie and the moment the moment the
moment at the very end when they go from
one film to to episode or to do episode
four right am i getting it right yoda am
i getting it right
he's very mad at me right now he's very
[ __ ] mad at me yoda is very upset in
the comments i don't know my star wars
[ __ ] but that moment when they when they
go from the end of rogue one um to to
the new hope it's like holy [ __ ] right
like that's like that's crazy that is
like
and the whole movie leading up to it is
[ __ ] fantastic but like i will watch
the whole movie just to get that feeling
from one to the other and i like like on
on disney i'll just click that one and
as soon as it's over i'll watch the
first part of the next one right just
just it's [ __ ] absolutely phenomenal
yoda says he ain't mad
he ain't man he ain't mad at me yoda's
not mad at me you know
i i get it i get it you know you know
the other thing that pisses some of my
friends off that love star wars i'm like
i like the first three episodes i like
them yeah they're different yeah they
get all pissed off like ah those aren't
star wars movies or those suck i'm like
no they're they're part of the whole
[ __ ] collection i i like those i like
episode one i like that one
i like when darth vader is a kid he's
not darth vader yet right like i like
that anakin sorry sorry yoda anakin
jesus
christ
all right let's let's get back to the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends what
else do we have there's just so much
oscar news um uh but uh right now the
jared kushner story is trending
in the for for you the for me as george
han would say
i don't know what this is i have no idea
i have no idea what this means
um
shane cometh the jared kushner story
greg wrote this apparently
let's see what greg has to say at the
time this the states hit the hardest by
coven 19 where new york
new jersey and california he was willing
to let the population those states home
to his family and friends get sick and
die to help his father-in-law's
re-election prospects so it sounds like
um
greg is saying
that
that
on
the covet 19
jared kushner it looks like the story
here
is that
he was willing to let people in new york
new jersey and california die
because he wanted trump to get reelected
we we got oh chris ends here
yeah chris is here what what is this um
oh man we got some we got some crazies
in the chat here we got some crazies
uh let's see so it won't retweet this i
don't know what this is i don't what
this jared kushner story is yet
but we'll see what um
see what everyone else says what's going
on here
of course everyone wants jared kushner
charged with crimes which i don't think
is out of the question here it's been a
long time since we heard from jared
kushner uh ivanka right
like it's been a long time
like it's almost like they're hiding or
something or maybe they're squealing or
something who is this person let's see
here
yeah i i can't i don't like it sorry i i
i if you're going to be a you know chris
you're welcome here
but the whole spam
chat thing
nope yeah you can't take it it can't
take and you're not gonna fill up the
[ __ ] chat with your spammy little
thing whatever the hell that was i don't
know what that was i have no idea
all right let's see
[Music]
um
let's go back i don't know if that's
that that's something that's that's
going on fidel castro
is trending why is fidel fidel
fidel trending
what is it oh justin trudeau oh you guys
heard this story have you guys heard
this story about [ __ ] uh canada have
you heard this [ __ ]
have you heard this oh my god
these there's like tens of truckers that
are
doing a convoy these [ __ ] right
wingers are jerking off to this stuff
absolutely ridiculous like 95 of all
trucking is still happening in canada
there's like five truckers that go to
ottawa or some [ __ ]
we get we we got some people from canada
that are fans of the show they watch
every week every day they watch
you seen this stuff what what what
should i search here to find this story
i haven't really paid attention to it or
talked about it much because it's
[ __ ] dumb
this is the same stupid [ __ ]
crt jfk voodoo type [ __ ] where they're
making up all kinds of [ __ ] about what's
gonna happen
let's see um i'm trying to think
well
truckers surely that'll get us there huh
truckers
here we go reuters has it
um let's see
oh this [ __ ] idiot
this [ __ ]
jack posiak or whatever the [ __ ] his
name is jack piece of [ __ ] jack p os
he's been up there he's been propagating
this stuff you know the pizzagate guy
that [ __ ]
who who stoked people to go shoot people
at a pizza parlor where there was no
basement telling them that there's a
[ __ ] basement
this [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] uh
here here's steve schmidt a memo to
america media the stated goal of the
truckers quote unquote is to overthrow
the democratically elected government of
canada
it's an insurrection of course fox news
trump ingraham desantis and all the rest
are trying to make it all burned down
dangerous days
uh so as steve schmidt is saying here
let's
what the
did this person start another [ __ ]
what is going on here
jesus christ
okay um
i don't know what the [ __ ] is in the
chat what is this [ __ ] who is that who
is that
oh they they keep creating an account
okay
all right well
there they are again
and there again look at this what what
who is this
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
oh my god
just just keep blocking them just keep
blocking them trying to distract me from
my show here you know i start talking
about the truckers maybe this is jack
this is jack pos coming in the chat
they're like oh my god he's talking
about the truckers he's gonna call him
fascist he's gonna say they're trying to
overthrow the government of canada which
like that's truly their goal like
they've said it they want to overthrow
the government right
by honking their horns
literally that's what they're doing
they're honking their horns in canada
um the news here that
uh steve is retweeting his fox news is
currently taking to the sons joe
warmington about the protest joe makes
no mention of the organizer's interest
in overthrowing canada's democratically
elected government and assists it's all
peaceful
and not any kind of insurrection
but man if you have to if you have to
say like if you have to come out and say
out loud it's not it's not an
insurrection oh we're not trying to take
over
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we're not trying to take over the
government we're not trying to take over
the government that's not what we're
trying to do
maybe you are right
and maybe you are so here's a video and
this is um
tom marazzo this guy here that's that's
speaking
um it says in an emergency press
conference the trucker's new
spokesperson
says i'm willing to sit at the table
with the conservatives the ndp and the
block as a coalition
i'll sit with the governor general
which i don't know about much about the
canadian government but apparently the
governor general has nothing to do with
anything like they don't have any like
power over what the hell they're talking
about let's listen to this [ __ ]
bonehead
we're here to talk
let's find a peaceful
peaceful resolution to this i want to go
home
so go the [ __ ] home
go home will ya come on i want to go
home
but i'm not i'm not going until i'm i no
longer need it here
and based on all the support that we
have from the people of canada i have an
incredible amount of support and a lot
of people that seem to want me here and
i'm not going home until the job is done
what what job what are you talking about
go do your job that's what people want
people want you to go do your job like
you know it is really [ __ ] nuts the
same [ __ ] that tell other
people go just just
just go do your job quit complaining
just go do your job
are the same [ __ ]
that are now saying i want to do my job
but i can't because i'm whiny
okay i am not calling for violence i'm
not expecting you to get into your
vehicle drive here and create uh
problems create crimes
so he's he
i don't please whatever you do
please whatever you do don't come here
and cause trouble
that's not what we're saying
strength in numbers we got sent here to
send a message
the message isn't getting through
he's not getting it and i apologize if
i'm bashing the guy but honestly from my
assessment he's got a
a 22 caliber mind in a 357 world
okay
let's get at a table for god's sakes
enough
hiding
i'm willing i'm willing
to sit at a table with the conservatives
and the ndp
who the [ __ ] is this guy
like
that's
this is not how democracy works at all i
get all you don't just because you don't
like something get to go talk to the
government you can protest you can sure
as hell protest you can get your
representatives the people who represent
you in the government
you can get them
you can get them
to do that like you can go you can go
over and you can get them to protest
and then and you can get the
representatives to change your mind
because of a protest or maybe a
conversation but you don't like get to
just take out a democratically elected
leader because
10 of you don't like him
like that's not [ __ ] democracy that's
not even close to what it is you dumb
[ __ ] that's the problem that we
have these people are [ __ ]
totalitarian they love totalitarianism
they love it they [ __ ] love that one
person can fix all their problems
they're so [ __ ] desperate to be to be
entitled that they think one person can
give them all the entitlements that they
want and need
and that's why the [ __ ] right wingers
in this country love that these people
in canada are doing this because there's
one thing that that [ __ ] fascists
understand in this country is that the
only way the only way for fascism to
take hold is to continue to do it all
around the world
right
all around the world
[ __ ] ridiculous
pro fence supply says gun analogy yeah
they well they're always you know these
people who don't we don't want anyone to
stoke violence don't do that always with
the gun analogies it's like the lady um
where the [ __ ] was that in virginia
where she went into a school board
meeting and she basically said i'm gonna
bring my guns and [ __ ] and then she went
and apologized to the police
like almost immediately
almost immediately
let's see [ __ ] this guy
let's give some credit here we showed
these videos let's give some credit
i'm gonna um yeah i'll retweet this
video
let's see we read this one i gotta go
back to the whole thread here
back to the whole thread
all right so now we're back to the
truckers thing
so there's a lot of this trucker stuff
and the reason why there's a lot of this
trucker stuff is because of
trucker carlson at [ __ ] stone kettle
says the basic model new p
runs about 160 000 a full decked out
model could be three times that
how many of these truckers own their
rigs free and clear how many have a
mortgage on top of that how many can
afford to sit idle because tucker
carlson wants to bring the country down
listen listen to this [ __ ] fool
what would happen if american truck
drivers decide they'd had enough of
people like joe scarborough and went on
strike what would happen then
well this country would stop immediately
no more deliveries of anything over time
that would mean starvation for people in
the cities
but even in the short term there would
be profound suffering in this country
for example and this is something that
too few people outside of television
even consider
the world's entire supply of botox is
manufactured on the west coast of
ireland that's a long way from here in
fact it's a 4 000 mile long supply chain
from the allergan plant in westport
ireland to jupiter
now people msnbc might not be aware of
this but our country has no domestic
botox production
along with vitamin c and antibiotics
it's one of the life-saving
pharmaceutical products we have
recklessly offshored
so if the trucks stop delivering the
botox stops coming and suddenly your
morning television anchors are going to
look like they're 58 years old which
actually they are
could that happen is it impossible no
it's not impossible
the people in charge aren't really
thinking this through
most of the time trends started the
united states and they moved north to
canada but this time the opposite could
happen
what in the [ __ ] is this guy talking
about
first is the m m's now it's joe
scarborough getting botox as if anyone
gives a rat's ass rather joe
scarborough
gets [ __ ] botox
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] so
what tucker carlson is suggesting is we
should seize up the american economy and
the american supply chains because
joe scarborough gets botox and because
you're a fascist and you want to take
the [ __ ] economy down and you and you
want to [ __ ] you want to starve the
economy of life-saving prescriptions you
really are a dumb [ __ ] this is
dumber than the [ __ ]
green m m's doesn't wear sexy boots [ __ ]
anymore
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
tucker what would happen if american
truck drivers decide that they'd have
enough and people like scarborough went
on strike
oh [ __ ]
look the union doesn't go on strike
because joe scarborough says something
you dumb [ __ ]
see this is this is the problem this is
the problem is he's [ __ ] fascist
don't understand what a [ __ ] labor
union is for a labor using union isn't
for
cutting off your own supply chain in
your own work and your own pay because
you don't like joe scarborough like a
union would be like yeah [ __ ] yeah we're
gonna deliver truck loads of botox to
joe scarborough that means money in our
pocket
you these [ __ ] fascists start start
so far into the nazi hole that they
can't even see the light a day
truckers are not going to boycott
because joe scarborough says something
bad
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
you are a [ __ ] bonehead and even in
canada where they're trying to make it
seem like every single trucker is off
the road in canada which is not [ __ ]
true not even close to the [ __ ] truth
there's tens of truckers
dozens
of truckers that are off the road and
there's tons tons of crisis actors up
there that are making it appear if
there's even more of them get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
this this [ __ ] botox eminem having
[ __ ] rube i am so [ __ ] sick and
tired of having to play clips of this
dumb [ __ ]
jesus christ
what in the [ __ ] is going on that he's
thinking that the entire
does he think that every truck in this
country delivers botox or some [ __ ]
is that what he thinks
does he think that every trucker oh they
gotta be manly men and manly men gotta
listen to me
you really are
you really are you got your [ __ ] head
so far up your own [ __ ] ass
tucker carlson what a [ __ ] what a
complete
utter [ __ ] dumbass
truckers should i have went to this
thread we're 25 minutes into the second
hour
here 25 minutes into the second hour
i'm glad we um
brought gabe on to do the oscars thing
because there you know there's let's go
back to the trendy trends here oh
hunter's trending now
hunter hunter it must be hunter biden oh
my god his laptop must be running for
secretary of state somewhere hunter
biden's laptop
stop the presses
[ __ ]
it's a slow day today it's a slow day in
politics
um joe rogan experience is trending
you guys uh see the the joe rogan stuff
you know we did uh
several minutes on it yesterday but just
to recap just to recap um for a second
here i think joe rogan is completely
[ __ ] um
and then the reason why i think he's
[ __ ] is not because people did away
their subscriptions uh to spotify i
actually think the reason why he's
[ __ ] is because the rock dwayne
johnson uh devalued him a lot
a lot
um especially when he came out and he
gave that stupid [ __ ] apology after
the rock slam dunked him
there is there is nothing in politics
trending does anyone what let's see
yeah lisa says i don't know how many
people watch this [ __ ] i don't
understand you're talking about tucker
carlson
mj says i can't stand him
uh angela says 150 trucks is that how
many trucks that they're confirming the
trucks that are in ottawa because listen
um i know trucking companies like i know
people who own trucking companies like
they own them and a lot of times they'll
own like a dozen [ __ ] vehicles right
like they don't just own one truck i
mean sometimes they're an owner operator
like here they're an owner operator so
like they're they they contract their
truck
right so sometimes they contract it with
one company sometimes they contract it
with other comp
companies sometimes they're hauling one
type of thing
like um
you know during certain parts of the
year there's there's crops that need to
be hauled so there's there's special
equipment that hauls crops whether it be
apples or wheat or corn milk whatever
that is you know a lot of times so they
own a fleet of trucks
right
um and sometimes it's specialty stuff
sometimes it's not and then sometimes
again it's like a trucking company so
that they're actually where you're
paying to have your load sent on that
truck right where you're freighting it
maybe it's maybe it's 20 pallets of x y
and z
maybe it's something different right
and there's also trucking companies that
have contracts big jumping trucking
companies like in the teamsters like
yellow right uh yellow is a big teamster
trucking company and where the union's
in
you know sometimes there's big companies
like that now fedex is another trucking
company right there they're logistics
so
but a lot of times owner operators
sometimes they'll own just one truck but
sometimes they'll own several and
they're hired drivers to drive those
trucks to drive that equipment
right so like in theory in theory let's
say there's 150 trucks that's what
angel's saying and angels say yes
there's 150 trucks so in theory let's
say let's say they got i don't know
let's say they got about 50 people
right 50 truckers who own three trucks
apiece and they ordered their three
trucks to go to ottawa
all right well that's 150 trucks
like it's like it's literally um in the
grand scheme of things yeah is it going
to stop some supply chains and going to
slow some stuff down yeah probably
probably especially in certain regions
of canada like if if these people are
pulling you know
more trucks off the road in certain
regions but here's my guess here's my
guess let's say it's a guy
let's say it's a guy or a gal who owns a
trucking company and let's say they got
20 trucks
right let's say they got 20 trucks and
they decided to pull two of their trucks
but the rest of the 18 are on the road
because they got to pay the [ __ ]
bills they can't have all [ __ ] 20
trucks down there honking their horns
and acting like they're going to take
over the government god damn they won't
make any [ __ ] money they'll be
[ __ ] flat broke think about this for
a second it's not just one try one
driver one truck right it's not what it
ain't like voting
when you have capitalism like this
it's you can own more than one [ __ ]
truck
you just pay someone to drive the truck
and if you're paying someone to drive
the truck you're like yeah you're gonna
pay i'm gonna pay you to drive the truck
down to ottawa you're gonna park it
you're gonna honk your horn you're gonna
cause a bunch of commotion and that's
what i'm gonna pay you to do
this is not rocket science it really
isn't this is all orchestrated it's all
[ __ ] it's all fake it's it's [ __ ]
nonsense it's craziness
and it's all so that the propagandist on
the internet and on tv can act like
the government in canada is falling
that's why the government canada's not
really paying attention to these [ __ ]
other than they're causing all kinds of
commotion and [ __ ] up everyone in
that [ __ ] community
as i seen videos of these [ __ ] idiots
honking their horns late at night uh-huh
concoct just on and on and on and on and
on it goes
uh tony says ups is union fedex is
non-union yeah yeah oh yeah there's some
there's some companies that that are
unionized some that aren't uh yellow
yellow is one of the big freighters um
in the country that is teamster and i i
know that
years and years ago i used to load a
truck for load trucks for a company like
i was the guy on the forklift putting
the [ __ ] pallets in the truck
like i i did that at one time in my life
i loaded trucks to all stuff and
actually we loaded trucks that hauled to
canada believe it or not but we all we
loaded trucks that went all over the
country at this at this distribution
plant and we loaded them it was books
that we were loading books
you know the things they want to burn
now
it wasn't botox tucker carlson it was
books i know we loaded these trucks full
of books and
they would ship them all over the
country to their other warehouses and
you know all kinds of [ __ ] all kind of
bookstores big warehouses for bookstores
barnes and noble and all that [ __ ]
right
but we we would load the trucks
and and part of them were union trucks
some of them we would load fedex trucks
we'd load ups trucks we'd load yellow
trucks we'd load all these different
these different carriers
and it depends on where they were going
and you know what when they were
supposed to get there what the load was
like who they contracted to ship that
load
but it wasn't like
i mean again in this country there are
owner operators where they just own one
truck
they and sometimes they contract with
one company right but they don't own
like the trailer they just own the truck
right they'll come we would load the
trailer and then they would come and
they would pick up the truck or the the
truck would come pick up the trailer and
they'd take it wherever it was supposed
to go and then that driver would get
paid for their for for the
transportation of that load
right now sometimes these people their
owner operators but they also own more
trucks that they hire drivers to drive
those trucks to haul goods around and
sometimes they not only just own the the
rig the truck they own the trailer as
well it's like for special goods you
know whether it's crops or something of
that nature you know there's there's a
lot of specialty trucking as well
these people are [ __ ] dumb and tucker
carlson not knowing what the [ __ ] he's
talking about when he's talking about
trucking and trucks and botox get the
[ __ ] out of here you dumb [ __ ]
why don't you [ __ ] take five minutes
five minutes call a couple people who
have been in the [ __ ] freight
business before for longer than 10
seconds and ask them how it [ __ ]
works like supply chains and [ __ ]
and then and then go on your stupid
[ __ ] show and act like you know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about this
[ __ ]
yoda says tucker is projecting for his
greatest fears you know well
he projects a lot uh pro fence supply
says did you see the guy in canada
whining about 150 cops coming to take
their fuel oh yeah yeah yeah so it's so
um there's a picture of it i actually
didn't see the video that you're talking
about but i did see a picture where they
had wheelbarrows full of fuel and they
were confiscating their fuel or whatever
because they're trying to keep these
trucks going i guess um
apparently and it might be a little
chilly in canada this time of year but
the video i did see was
like in the middle of the day it was
just constant like they're blaring their
horns and blaring their horns which
realistically is uh when you're
disturbing the piece i'm sure there's
they have city ordinances about
disturbing the peace like you can
protest and you can have a protest but
you can't you can't cross the boundary
of protest to where you're you're just
you're just causing noise
and disruption like you can
sometimes that is part of a protest but
once you once you're only the disruption
and noise and you're not actually
protesting anything anymore you've gone
beyond your boundary
yoda says no botox
and maybe hashtag that no botox
um
angela says the a judge banned hawking
for 10 days
seems bigger problems blockades at the
border
uh yeah so they're so they're blocking
um they're blocking stuff too um which
is causing those supply chain issues and
that's really their their their game
here their game interest is to try to
choke down supply chains so that people
can't get stuff so to piss people off
right
um to try to show to try to show people
that they have power over their over
their lives right this is the things
that fascists do
the things that fascists do
is they use their they wield their power
to prove to someone else that they're
superior right like in a union dispute
in a union dispute in this country like
if truckers weren't getting paid what
they're supposed to get paid or they
felt like they they needed to be paid
more for their labor for what they were
doing they would they would walk off the
job and they would
they would
uh
protest
for more jobs to negotiate for better
pay for themselves not not to hurt
someone else like their intention isn't
to hurt
someone else that they're superior to
right that their ideas are superior of
like that's the thing that these
fascists don't really [ __ ] understand
and they're making it sound like and
you're gonna see a lot of this [ __ ] um
these these [ __ ] especially these
white male maga
fragility [ __ ] out there who
are in unions uh who infiltrated unions
and they act like it's some kind of
democratic
institution like it must you must be
you must be not a republican and not a
fascist if you're in a union which is
that's all [ __ ] and
you're gonna see the infiltration of
some of this stuff and they try to use
the the union as a wedge of oh both
sides are the same both sides are
exactly the same you know republicans
are bad and democrats bad type [ __ ]
right that's what fascists they do that
[ __ ] too and that's what this projection
is into our country
because that's why these american
fascists are getting so excited and
they're funding the stuff in canada is
because they can say look see they're a
democracy look how bad it is there
because they can't manage to do that
[ __ ] here right they're not able to to
stuff up the [ __ ] supply chains
because the supply chains that you know
they bitched about our supply chains
after covet happened
after the economy was ramping up then
the supply chains had to be fixed and
repaired and get them back in order
you know and it took it took private
business and corporations a little bit
to do it some of it was a little
intentional so they could increase
prices because i think there is some
price gouging going on i don't think
it's all inflation i think there's price
gouging as well
and i don't i think anyone out there who
doesn't believe that there's a little
bit of price gouging well [ __ ] you don't
know capitalism very goddamn well
you haven't been participating for that
long there's definitely price gouging
going on somewhere angela says uh the
truckers in ottawa brought in showers
and saunas not kidding so they're having
a party right this is a party to them
and they're trying to overthrow the
government here is what they're trying
to do and this is what these fascists do
anything they can anything they can to
feel superior and to [ __ ] take over
governments and smash up everyone else's
beliefs they hate democracy
they [ __ ] hate it they [ __ ] hate
it because they can't tell other people
how they're better than them and they
can't oppress their views on other
people
look if you don't want a vaccine
fine
fine don't get one
fine make your choice do what you want
leave us to let rest of us the [ __ ]
alone
stop
stop acting like you're [ __ ]
oppressed because that is what they're
trying to make this about is the vaccine
that's what these fascists are trying to
do in this country when they go into a
burger king and complain they can't get
a [ __ ] whopper they go to the olive
garden and complain they can't get the
[ __ ] salad
the reason why they're [ __ ] doing
this is because they're trying to
[ __ ] convince people that they're
being that white people that they're
being oppressed you're not being
oppressed you're oppressing yourselves
you made the decision to do what you
were going to do so live with that
[ __ ] decision why are you bitching at
the rest of us that you made the
decision that's causing your hardship
everyone else made their decision
including you
just because you decided not to do
something doesn't mean you get to you
get to oppress the rest of us
it's a contagious deadly pathogen
and the rest of us say we don't want to
get sick so you don't get to do this
stuff if you don't [ __ ] do the thing
that the data and the science tells us
you should do which is keep everyone
safe you dumb [ __ ]
quit being such whiny [ __ ] snowflakes
get in your goddamn trucks go home and
park your truck if you don't want a
truck anymore
we don't give a i'm sure the people in
canada could care [ __ ] less if these
150 trucks went and parked their asses
somewhere and [ __ ] just shut the [ __ ]
up and and went on with their live their
non-vaccinated lives
their non-vaccinated lives i'm sure they
would just be completely fine with that
they wouldn't give two [ __ ]
but they don't want these dumb
[ __ ] crying and pissing and
moaning
about how they're superior
because that's what this is it's a
superiority complex i don't i shouldn't
have to get it and i should get what i
want because i'm white
don't believe me
you don't believe me go go look at some
of this [ __ ] go look at some of these
anti-backs rallies
go look at them go to the [ __ ]
facebook the ivermectin institute groups
go look over there
don't believe me i'm telling you that's
what this is and and it's being funded
by american fascists this [ __ ] canada
trucker thing
it's all it's all because the right way
you know we we goofed them we clowned
them about the restaurants right so they
went in all these [ __ ] restaurants
they did this the last month and the
month before
it's the same [ __ ] thing
as them going into the burger king and
causing a big scene and having the new
york or the new york city police
arresting them it's the same [ __ ]
it's the same stupid [ __ ] and the
political theater
you know that that they're doing here
is to to make themselves feel oppressed
oh
oh my god
oh
it's so it's so egregious that you would
require me
to get a vaccine so that way i don't get
other people sick
we've always done that like always
and for for americans
for americans to act like that these
truckers are going to somehow overthrow
the government in canada
you people really are [ __ ] boneheaded
i mean just completely [ __ ]
boneheaded that you think that these
truckers are somehow gonna make sure
that they get to take over the
government in canada and
and make sure there's no mandates or
whatever whatever the [ __ ] their goal is
here
whatever the [ __ ] it is
i don't even know what they have a goal
other than other than to spread fascism
i know that's what jack posiak or
whatever the [ __ ] that
ninka poop's name is
uh
let's see should we should we go back to
the trendy trends of the tweety tweets i
don't know i like this subject
i like this subject tony says
manufactured
manufactured crisis yes it is a
manufacturer crisis
it is a manufactured crisis
manufactured that's what they do they
manufacture crisis crises
um
robin says apparently 95 or 97 of canyon
truckers are actually vaccinating yeah
well that's that's because probably 95
to 97 percent of truckers get it
like they get it like they get why
they're they're being required to get a
[ __ ] vaccine
they get it because they travel across
the road and they go from one part of
the country to the other and it's very
[ __ ] dangerous to take someone who
travels from from place to place across
a large region
and spread a disease from one part of
the region to another part of the region
what you'd want to do is make sure that
you were doing your damnedest not to
infect other parts of the
country unknowingly especially when
there's especially when there's a proven
vaccine to help in that effort
like yeah vaccines aren't perfect they
never have been they never will be
especially especially as we take on with
this coronavirus thing you know it's
going to take a while i mean this is
still new
i mean never in the history have we ever
had it had this disease like coronavirus
and had a vaccine that was so effective
so fast we've never had it it's and
we've never done that now we've always
had this challenge with vaccines
because people are you know
it's human nature to be hesitant for
someone to tell you what to do and you
should be skeptical like that's what
science is
science is is
they're skeptical as [ __ ]
like that's the whole thing they keep
saying oh you're changing your minds
it was one thing eight months ago and
now it's another that's because science
is skeptical
it's it's not it's not just it's not
just a [ __ ] dictatorship you dumb
[ __ ]
they have to have evidence they have to
have data
they have to they have to prove that
something is the way it is otherwise
they won't believe it because they're
skeptical
i don't know how the right wing has
turned this around on us
but that's how this is
science
and medicine
are skeptical like that's the whole
point we want them to be
and you should be skeptical you
absolutely should be
skeptical of things when you hear them
you should say is that true i don't know
let's check it out
let's check it out before i believe that
thing just all of a sudden
now depending on the evidence that you
already have you might be able to
discern whether something's true or not
whether something's misinformation or
disinformation this all goes back to
[ __ ] joe rogan
and joe rogan
spreading his [ __ ] lies and his
[ __ ] buffoonery
because ultimately at the end of the day
that's what is deadly about joe rogan's
show
is that he's convincing a shitload of
people including [ __ ] truckers in
canada i can't i can't probably even um
tell you if there is a hundred it's if
it's actually 150 truckers not 150
trucks but i mean there's got to be
these drivers but 150 drivers that are
participating in this thing
um i i would imagine that 97 of them
probably are joe rogan listeners
right
like you know they get their [ __ ]
vaccine advice from joe rogan like aaron
rodgers gets his it gets his sports and
medical advice from joe rogan
right
but that's where we're at in this
[ __ ] timeline it's so [ __ ] up
that they think they're some kind of
[ __ ] hero because they got a
superiority complex you're not a [ __ ]
hero when you got a superiority complex
when unions when unions pick it
and they walk off the job they're
walking they're not walking off the job
to hurt someone else
that's not what they're doing
they're walking off the job so them and
all the laborers the workers
get paid what they're supposed to get
paid
to get the deal that they're supposed to
get
not to [ __ ] someone else intentionally
not because you have a superiority
complex
and you think you're
better not what it is
and they really got it twisted in their
[ __ ] minds
and that's where that's where they live
and and you know
speaking of
earlier speaking of the
interview with dakota adams stewart
rhodes's estranged son he talks about
how trump has has has narrowed this
spectrum
right of fascism in this country and i
believe he's 100 percent dead on right
uh angela says 150 trucks not drivers
yeah i figured that much
i figured that much that they were that
it was you know tens of drivers
tens of drivers
and they were you know packing the
trucks in with tens of drivers
just
[ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ]
but they're making the choice not to be
vaccinated right
and they call it a mandate but it's not
really even a mandate it's a requirement
because you don't i mean you don't have
to [ __ ] drive a truck you're not
required you're not mandated to drive a
truck
how many [ __ ] do these people not
understand freedom and liberty at all
like at all they don't understand it
and our and our uh great neighbors to
the north canada
you know in their democracy their
liberties and freedoms are a little
different than ours a little but not by
a lot
a little bit here a little bit there
because it's a different type of
democracy a different constitution than
we have
but it's it's very similar
in the in the way of that how they have
liberty and freedom in that country and
the way that we have it here
right
and what a lot of people understand is
your your free what we strive for is
liberty
that's what we strive for is the actual
liberty that's what delivers us equality
that's what delivered us equity
that's that's what delivers us the
freedom of speech
you want you want your guns your second
amendment
it's liberty that delivers you that
not the actual freedom or the right
itself
if you don't believe me you just talk to
any any felon that wants to carry a
firearm
some states they can some states they
can't
because those freedom and rights
are can be regulated
you can't go into a burning or a theater
and yell fire if it's not burning down
you can't do that right
so this idea that someone's holding
these people down and forcing them to
get vaccinated is really [ __ ] dumb
it's really [ __ ] dumb tony points
makes a good point here he says 1.4
million teamsters not counting
independent trucker unions
150 of these 150 trucks not drivers
trucks
and it just they don't
understand liberty they don't get it and
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty
it's not
you don't you do not get to oppress the
rights of other people
and other people have the right to to
freely move about their way
to to make sure that supply chains are
open
right that's the freedom and the right
of other people
and you don't get to oppress those
rights because you're superior that's
called
fascism
you really you really you [ __ ]
bone-ins you fascist boneheads out there
you know and and again you know the the
the tens of drivers in canada that are
participating in the stupid [ __ ]
thing and all these [ __ ] these
fascists in america who are cheering us
on like tucker carlson and jack piece of
[ __ ] and piece of [ __ ] jack posiak or
whatever the [ __ ] his name is [ __ ] that
pizza gate [ __ ] [ __ ] him
but those fascists
they love this oh they love this because
they can really get simple-minded
[ __ ] people to believe that the
fascism is being oppressed on them
that the mandate the requirement is
being oppressed on them you're making
the decision to be a trucker
you you do that that's what you do you
decided to do it you had the freedom and
the liberty to be a trucker
and you have the freedom and liberty not
to be
you don't have to be
canada's not a communist state
it's not a fascist state i mean they
want it to be these fascists want it to
be
these totalitarian truckers i mean
that's what we call them
the totalitarian truckers
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
all right
i appreciate you guys hanging out with
us today i really do
i really do it's fun
it's fun we did the shitless roundup we
had gabe on again either tomorrow or
thursday probably looking more like
thursday
we will have an interview with jojo from
jurors
so i'll try to tag jojo and if we don't
have it tomorrow we'll talk about it
tomorrow too
well we'll talk about this tomorrow too
but we'll get we're gonna have jojo for
jurors from jurors on here
uh you guys know her her twitter account
she's one of our faves here but she's
gonna be we she did an interview with us
she recorded we had a lot of fun uh we
we had some um lighting issues
because of the time of day that she she
was doing it but but i i think you know
gabe will be able to wave his magic wand
i i don't know
but but we had a lot of fun with joe so
so go watch that um she talks about her
twitter account she talks about uh some
of the challenges
about having twitter account but also
how it matters um so anyone out there
that has a twitter account that that
likes to spread the pro-democracy
message around um come listen to what
joe has to say
because i do i do think it is important
again rather you have 200 followers or
200 000 followers
i think your voice is important to to
spread a pro-democracy message and
there's a lot of different um
types of a voice that you can have you
can get down in the comments you can
retweet you can tweet yourself
um you know and and all that's part of
messaging if you don't believe that the
the interwebs have something to do with
messaging i'll i have an election in
2016 and like to sell you
russian propaganda really helped push
that one over the edge
and then propaganda is always a bad word
right
it's always a bad word but we got to get
our messaging straight because we have
to stay pissed on this thing we have to
have strategic outrage as you've heard
rachel bitkoffer on this program several
times even yesterday she was on
talking about the gift of
of the phrase legitimate political
discourse that they did this weekend
after mike pence said in front of a
microphone trump is wrong
he's a fascist we don't do that he's
un-american it's what he called him he
called him un-american
and democrats are in disarray get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you can drive wedges in between these
republicans you can you can do it in
your own district right let's say two
republicans are running against each
other one's trump one's one's for trump
one's kind of not you can drive wedges
in between them get on twitter start
[ __ ] agitating them
you know i mean don't get put in twittmo
but ask them questions draw conclusions
from them you know see if one supports
pence one supports trump
you know we can drive wedges in between
these son of a [ __ ] we can do it
we can do it we can force them to make
these to make these decisions to drive
wedges in between themselves to divide
up their vote
they do it to us they've always tried to
do it to us they've always tried to give
us no confidence
in what if a state's blue or state's red
all these states are blue
georgia's blue texas blue hell alabama
louisiana you don't think they're blue
[ __ ] they are
they are they're all blue
they're blue
it's just they convince us that they're
not and that's why we have to stay
pissed we have to have strategic outrage
and we have to go [ __ ] vote
we have to go [ __ ] vote and i don't
just mean mark a ballot
i mean you have to get engaged in some
way in some fashion maybe you're good at
something
i don't know maybe you're good at text
messaging
find a campaign find find a find
somewhere where you can help get the
word out by texting
maybe you like to talk on the phone go
talk on the phone maybe you like to to
meet people in person
you know that covet is really put a
damper on people meeting people in
person
put your mask on you're vaccinated
you're fully boosted
go out there
knock on some doors find a campaign you
can knock on some doors beto o'rourke is
doing a fantastic job in texas he's all
over the place down there
there's a place where we could turn blue
because i know it is
we don't have to turn it blue it is blue
we just have to convince all the people
who would vote blue
that yes if you come out and vote if you
crawl over hot lava you can get your
[ __ ] power grid back in decent shape
if you put people in power that would
actually [ __ ] do something about it
they would work for you oh there's a
[ __ ] there's a [ __ ] novel idea
democracy
you elect representatives to get [ __ ]
done to do you know things like
government
not take away people's liberty make sure
the power grid is up and running when
you need it up and running
that's what's happening in texas
they had a whole year a whole [ __ ]
year
to help the power grid nope didn't do
that
they took away women's liberty that was
their priority and gave everyone guns
take away women's liberty and give
everybody guns
you know pro-life type [ __ ]
put women's health in danger and put
everyone else in danger because you give
everyone guns this is the republican way
though they destroy everything
they want to destroy our democracy that
is their goal
that's where they're headed
don't believe me just ask them
just ask them
ask your family ask your you know your
trump humping maga friends
ask him
do you think what mike pence said is the
truth
that the vote is for we the people and
one person doesn't have the right to
overturn the election
do you believe that it is un un-american
that one person gets to decide who the
president is
wait for their answer he'll show him the
[ __ ] clip
like i said we need to cut that clip up
we need to cut it up in a certain way
that way you guys can show your family
and spread it around the internet
maybe we'll maybe we'll work on that
i'm not a super peck i'm just i'm just a
noise maker i don't do great ads we
don't have great ad we have funny ads
here we do the parodies thanks for
joining us for the shitless roundup
today i appreciate you guys coming to
the podcast remember remember you can
download the podcast if you want to
listen to the audio version on apple
spotify we are still on spotify
i've i've voiced my um my opinion about
going off spotify i'm not going to
de-platform this voice on spotify i
appreciate anyone else who wants to
that's their that's their right their
decision their freedom
but it's also mine and i will spread the
message of liberty as far and wide as i
can
on any platform that will have it we
will yell and scream into a microphone
even though most of our downloads aren't
apple
i don't know maybe maybe it's just that
uh most of my audience is apple users
and most of our downloads are in apple
some on google
very few on spotify but it's still over
there so go download it on your favorite
directory whatever that may be spotify
google
apple
whatever it may be go download the
episode also you can find us on youtube
twitter twitch live
live
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here youtube twitter
twitch
and until tomorrow until tomorrow at
noon eastern surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking